so very simply the cardinals win
they are in and the brewers win and they
are in austin gomberg gets the call in
this all-important game the low era 1.80
and what i really liked about gomber is
last time out and that was against
kansas city is the way he attacked the
zone and garcia stands in
in the air right field dexter father
over
and makes the catch and there's the
first out here's kristen yelich
and yelich up the middle of base hits so
milwaukee's first hit
and base runner yelling aboard with one
out and here comes ryan braun
backhanded out there the turn down
edmond juan goldsmith and gomber gets
out of
inning number one brett anderson the
lefty and the starter today for
milwaukee cardinals have seen him
already this year his last two starts
have been good ones colton wong is the
lead on batter
swinging a bouncer hit towards short
orlando arcia
as the plane throws him out anderson
faces tommy edmond
this one pushed to right field and brawn
is settling underneath it for out number
two
that'll bring up paul goldschmidt into
right that ball will get
down a base hit for paul goldschmidt so
the cardinals have their first hit
and the batter will be dylan carlson
swinging and a
fly into right playable and caught by
brawn and the ending is over cardinals
go to bat here in the bottom of the
second inning molina
will lead off the frame against brett
anderson this one hit into
left center and christian yelach on the
run with a nice catch
really nice catch by yellets he got a
good jump angled back able to grab it
one up and one down
and here's the young fly ball center
field garcia going back
all the way to the wall and just in
front of the wall crashes into it
another nice play two nice plays in a
row by the brewer
outfield it's a leadoff triple for
harrison bader
to start this third inning well there's
a good start to the inning there's some
damage for you
and now it's tyler o'neill and he walked
out you know brett anderson was looking
at his
his pitching hand after that all four he
has had blister issues
and that's what they're looking at
anderson is going to exit this game
wow absolutely huge turn of events here
and craig council's first call will go
to freddie peralta the new pop-up
he'll face colton wong with runners at
first and third and nobody out
o'neal is running and the throw to
second is
not in time and tyler somehow stayed on
the bag
how about that that's a gutsy move right
there off the glove of peralta
runners advance one is safe they throw
it away
two runs will score it's two-nothing st
louis
nightmare start to the bottom of the
third inning for the brewers
there's paul goldschmidt a swing and a
base hit left center field
one around third he's going to score
three-nothing cardinals
a frustrating afternoon it's starting to
turn out to be
for craig council and now paul deyoung
will hit the young
lines it into left field that ball's
going to get down for a hit
goldsmith scores four-nothing cardinals
in the third
a two-out hit for paul de young he's
walked the first two batters to open up
this fourth inning and open the door
for the brewers to try and put up a
crooked number and get back into it
that'll bring up jet jerko a one pitch
down and in and gets by molina back to
the backstop to
second goes braun the third goes yelich
3-2 pitch
swing and a miss he struck him out big
strikeout there well this will be if
he's able to get out of this
unscathed this will be his pitch of the
day now it's daniel vogelback
ground ball third base side that is
going to get a run home long throw
across the diamond is in time to get
vogel back
the brewers get a run across to make it
4-1
freddie peralta getting back at it he's
ready to work against
harrison bader and bader launches one
out to deep left
in the big man and he hit the painting
he hit the painting for fred bird you've
got to be
kidding me redbird where yet
oh yeah make it 5-1 cardinals
so two on now for milwaukee with one
down in the eighth inning ryan brown the
batter
3-2 pitch he struck him out
99 outside corner all right two down for
jet jerko
a swing and a miss he struck him out
just threw it right by him
99 miles an hour braun and jericho have
struck out and two on nobody out in the
eighth
yachty or molina there's a chance for
possibly three here do they turn it they
do a triple play nicely done defense
what he has never done in his career
before
he just bounced into a triple play and
the cardinals are one out away
and now the brewers have the tying run
at home plate and it's abby garcia
ground ball hit up the middle
wong is there throw to first and that'll
do it
it's been a wild and crazy regular
season and the cardinals find themselves
in a familiar spot
the saint louis cardinals are headed to
post-season play
in 2020 the 30th playoff appearance
all time for the st louis cardinals